une colocation pour personnes âgées à
ecquevilly c'est le projet de nathalie
et mehdi objectif proposer des services
et une surveillance 24 heures sur 24
tout en continuant sa vie normalement
une alternative aux ehpad
c'est une forme de all inclusive où les
personnes donc seront locataires de
leurs chambres meublées et aussi
partageront les espaces communs vous
avez pas mal de personnes qui vont en
ehpad
parce qu'elles ont peur de la solitude
et du coup ces sept personnes entre
rester chez elle toute seule et se
retrouvait en ehpad ben il ya la maison
des baies avec services pour la
nourriture les animations sortir et ça
chez vous tout seul c'est difficile de
reproduire ça la maison des b sera
composé de six chambres
un projet qui fait écho à une histoire
personnelle ma maman en fait en 2019 qui
a fait un avc et les médecins
préconisent et l'ehpad
on a lutté pour qu'elles n'aillent pas
dans un ehpad elle est rentrée à
domicile on a mis en place tous les
services nécessaires et on a vu en fait
qu'elles progressaient énormément pour
l'heure la maison est en travaux les
deux membres de la famille seront
soutenus par le dirigeant des artisans
bâtisseurs pour la partie technique
il y aura un agrandissement qui va être
fait il faut donc gérer toute la partie
administrative
il faut gérer aussi la partie technique
les parties des fondations et tout ça on
a vite fait de se tromper et de faire
des erreurs
d'autant plus qu'il devait y avoir à
l'intérieur puisque c'est un
investissement qui reçoit du public des
accès particulier il va y avoir des
règles particulières et qu'il faut les
mettre en musique avec l'ensemble des
corps de métiers acquise en juin dernier
la maison est situé au 24 rue des vignes
à ecquevilly le service ce devrait être
mis en place des bus 2022 budget prévu
quatre cent mille euros